notre second débat vous le savez en
explore régulièrement dans cette partie
de l'émission les grandes mutations de
notre société c'est le cas ce soir avec
ce que la pandémie change dans le monde
du travail télétravail est évidemment
est entré dans notre culture
professionnelle mais ce n'est pas la
seule mutation samia déchire certains
parlent ou rêve de la grande émission
[Musique]
pas sûr qu'ils partent tous avec autant
de panache que dans cette publicité
culte de la française des jeux mais les
français sont de plus en plus nombreux à
quitter leur travail en juillet 2021
plus de cent cinquante mille d'entre eux
ont démissionné d'un poste en cdi c'est
presque 20% de plus que deux ans
auparavant
la progression est moins impressionnante
mais tout de même significatif pour les
ruptures conventionnelles qui ont
progressé de plus de 6% sur la même
période un phénomène qui ne touche pas
que des cadres en quête de sens qui ne
veulent plus avoir des journées
entrecoupées de très longues pauses non
rémunéré être mal payé faire des boulots
fatiguant épuisant peu reconnu je pense
à la restauration je pense à la pauvreté
je pense
au métier d'enseignant dans les ehpad
c'est un peu le mythe ou du monde du
travail qui est en train de se vivre à
michel de la planète 5les en france
c'est que un certain nombre de choses
qu'on pensait être des états fait face
aujourd'hui ne sont plus acceptés et
c'est une prise de conscience collective
il s'agit en fait un levier très
puissant la france marche rethel dans
les pas des états unis où plus de 38
millions d'américains ont quitté leur
poste l'an dernier
les économistes restent prudents dans la
comparaison les feux n'a pas le côté
spectaculaire
et pour l'instant il est difficile de
faire un parallèle entre les deux est
une des raisons à mon sens ce qui a
limité cette incapacité fait que le
marché du travail n'est pas du tout le
même aux états unis et en europe
aujourd'hui on trouve un emploi très
rapidement quand on démissionne on est
en france fait beaucoup plus c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué autre nuance à
prendre en compte en 2020 les embauches
comme les démissions ont été gelés dans
une économie paralysée par le cos vide
la vague de départs de 2021 pourrait
aussi s'expliquer par un simple effet de
rattrapage
le travail post-pandémie voilà le thème
de notre vous présente
nos invités laurence breton qu'une libre
soit vous êtes vice présidente de
l'association nationale des drh
directeurs et directrices des ressources
humaines cécile cukierman bonsoir
bonsoir sénatrice de la loire porte
parole du parti communiste auteur d'un
rapport sénatorial sur le télétravail
originaire côte si tu vas où il faut
s'il faut il faut pas oublier les autres
aurélie jeantet bonsoir sa maîtresse de
conférences à l'université sorbonne
nouvelle vous êtes chercheur au
laboratoire cnrs crespy vous publiez les
émotions au travail aux éditions du cnrs
justement matthieu croissandeau toujours
à mes côtés alors dans ce débat il ya
beaucoup de thèmes passionnants à
aborder les démissions on y viendra la
quête de sens les secteurs qui arrivent
plus à embaucher devrait commencer par
le télétravail évidemment c'est pas la
panacée universelle il ya ça convient ni
à tous les secteurs ni à tous les
salariés mais est ce que vous diriez
quand même laurence breton qu'unique
nouvelle ère qui s'est ouverte une
nouvelle forme d'organisation qui est en
train de de s'imposer ou en tout cas
qu'elle a pour longtemps et oui tout
change en fait on a une accélération des
temps ça avait commencé bien avant le
copine mais quand on regarde le peu
d'accord que nous avions signé on se
rend compte qu'une fois qu'on a goûté en
tout cas au télétravail même si on le
rappelle sans mode dégradé un 3ème but
avec les enfants à la maison etc mais
néanmoins cette nouvelle forme
d'organisation du travail plaît alors on
répète toujours que tout doit être bien
cadré et surtout sa demande l'accord des
deux parties et tous les métiers sont ne
sont pas télétravail abl c'est à dire
qu'aujourd'hui en mode dégradé on est
contraint en fait de mettre énormément
de personnes en télétravail mais je
rappelle au delà du métier il y a près
et les aptitudes et compétences
personnelles qui font qu'on peut reste
en télétravail aujourd'hui en fait on
est beaucoup plus tolérant sur cette
partie un accélérateur en fait oui tout
à fait et ailleurs on le dit on parle du
modèle hybride et d'ailleurs on le voit
bien puisque dans les recrutements c'est
vraiment une demande à l embauche
toujours combien de jours avez-vous de
télétravail donc vraiment ces gens là
c'est la nouveauté c'est une évolution
dont on les rations ory jantes et c'est
vrai qu'on voit des jeunes diplômés ou
des gens qui essayent de changer de
secteur qui pose cette question combien
de jours de télétravail rond de pour
ceux qui sont en situation pouvoir
choisir avant que choisir l'entreprise
dans laquelle ils vont aller
oui alors vous le télétravail est
vraiment quand même une
transformation majeure et notre rapport
au travail parce qu'on est vraiment
passé d'une séparation très nette entre
les temps et les espaces de travail et
de leur travail à quelque chose de plus
poreux avec plus de circulation pour le
meilleur et pour le pire bien sûr ça
peut poser des difficultés mais c'est
vrai que ça correspond à une aspiration
de pas mal de personnes
voilà des jeunes effectivement
particulier mais pas seulement c'est
vrai qu'on y trouve notre compte pour
une grande part des personnes après il
faudra aussi faire les comptes justement
de quels sont les apports du télétravail
aussi qu'est ce qu'on perd oui oui
effectivement il ya huit actifs sur dix
ont cerné par le très bon travail qui
souhaite conserver la possibilité de
télétravailler après la crise étude de
du mois de juin dernier études et lab de
juin 2021 c'est celui qui incarne
effectivement il faut quand même on va
faire un peu le pour et le contre mais
ça n'a pas que des avantages le
télétravail faut pas être dans une
vision totalement paradisiaque où il dit
quoi mais tout d'abord je crois que ça a
été dit tout le monde ne pourra pas
télétravail sûr il ya le l'intérêt qu'il
peut être parfois personnelles et moi je
demeure attentive aussi à l'intérêt
collectif je demeure convaincu que le
travail a un rôle de sociabilisation des
individus quel que soit d'ailleurs le
travail que l'on fait il peut nous
plaire il peut me déplaire il peut être
contraignant peut être épanouissant mais
il a ce rôle de socialisation parce que
l'on rencontre l'autre donc bien
évidemment il ya un intérêt dans lequel
dans des situations souvent dégradés ça
a été dit parfois subi de la veille au
lendemain on s'est retrouvé en
télétravail on a pu y prendre bien
évidemment d d d d intérêt on y trouve
parfois même un intérêt on n'a pas
besoin de se lever aussi tôt le matin
pourrions bien glacé transport de
william du temps et souvent soirée un
temps de transport ou on le perd en
temps de repos
le père aussi dans la convivialité
parfois que quand on dit de rencontrer
l'autre et puis on va voir je crois
aussi une vraie question de société
c'est que c'est toute la question de
l'effort et du rapport au travail et
effectivement
il y as besoin de repenser et de toute
façon cette mutation du monde ultra
elles existent aujourd'hui mais en
faisant attention je crois de ne pas
raisonner chacun et surtout est ce ce
que une toiture dans le rapport un des
risques c'est une nouvelle division du
travail demain qui va alors elle aussi
bouleverser les repères de classe vous
me permettrez cette expression
précédente mais en tout cas entre ceux
qui pourront très travaillé qui pourrait
être vécue l'air comme des privilégiés
parce que justement elles n'auront pas
un certain nombre de contraintes quand
d'autres subiront en télétravail et ils
se sentiront pas si privilégié que ça et
voilà je crois que ça en tout cas tout
ceci qu'il faut être attentif mais nous
disons aussi il y a des intérêts en
termes d'aménagement du territoire
pourquoi il y a beaucoup de choses à
repenser et en tout cas je crois qu'on
sait où on va y revenir il faut bien que
quand avec elle même nous rejoindre
parce que justement à faire un focus sur
ce rapport rebond soir quand tu as donc
le sénat qui a tenté ses intérêts
semblent de ce s'accaparer ce phénomène
mais aussi de se projeter dans le futur
oui c'est la délégation à la prospective
c'est une entité qui existe d'ailleurs
que au sénat qui ne s'est pas la sonacc
essaie de faire ça équivalent apprend un
thème essaie de se projeter dans le
futur et on avait déjà des chiffres
intéressants effectivement thomas dans
ce rapport c'est naturel je vais vous
montrer déjà ce chiffre avant la crise
sanitaire des travail qui ne concerne
que 7% des actifs en france et les
sénateurs qui note qu un an plus tard ça
concerne 25% un quart des salariés
français qui saison en quêté en
télétravail qu'on paie alors certes il
ya la crise sanitaire qui a joué mais on
voit là une évolution majeure sur
laquelle on ne reviendra pas selon les
experts auditionnés par votre délégation
madame carmen car le télétravail est
rentré donc dans le quotidien de
nombreux salariés et en dehors de la
période qu'ovide les sénateurs parle
d'un télétravail qui pourrait concerner
jusqu'à 50% des actifs c'est sans doute
là le seuil maximal des emplois
télétravail à blé cela pourrait être à
un horizon 2050 mais on a quand même on
voit loin les sénateurs qu'on parlait de
parler de nouvelles opportunités et une
nouvelle contrainte voilà c'est ça c'est
tout le débat que vous êtes déjà en
train de commencer à avoir un sur le
plateau entre les avantages
inconvénients regarder au delà du site
de 50% retient d'autres conclusions d'un
rapport sénatorial notamment le fait que
s'il est bien organisé ils pètent
générateur de gains de productivité
notamment lorsque salariés et
volontaires déjà dit déjà en plateau ça
peut mettre jusqu'à 30 % de gains de
productivité et a pas forcément de
risque de localisation de l'emploi 10
les sénateurs mais plutôt un risque que
les actifs à y travailler ailleurs en
télétravail mais on va y revenir ensuite
le télétravail peut permettre de
nouvelles opportunités comme par exemple
pour les personnes handicapées il venait
aussi de nouveaux risques comme les
nouveaux risques comme la sédentarité ou
encore ce flou entre votre vie perso et
notre vie pro et enfin le télétravail
peut permettre d'accélérer l'exode
urbain vous l'avez déjà un tout petit
peu évoqué mari de kaman écoutez à ce
propos la sénatrice céline boulay
speroni qui est donc l'une des co
rapporteur avec vous avant si l'un des
conjoints devait partir à l'étranger ou
dans une ville moyenne dans une autre
ville que paris par exemple l'autre
devait trouver un travail sur place ou
n'avaient pas forcément de travail
pouvait se retrouver au chômage
maintenant grâce au télétravail toute la
famille peut déménager peut déménager
dans un logement qui est donc un peu
moins cher et s'y retrouver du point de
vue économique donc ça c'est quand même
une avancée formidable et le sénat a
émis des recommandations elle ça va
souvent avec les rapports et les
recommandations effectivement et donc il
propose par exemple de créer un
observatoire du télétravail pour
promouvoir notamment les bonnes
pratiques ça peut être intéressant aussi
pour les drh il appelle à être vigilant
sur l'attractivité du pays notamment
fiscales pour éviter que les salariés
mais il travaillait dans un territoire
plus attractif au luxembourg ou en
belgique par exemple le rapport milite
également en faveur d'investissements
comme des tiers lieux c'est ces espaces
de travail partagés avec de la fibre
dans les territoires où encore des
services publics pour encourager les
télétravailleurs à s'installer dans tel
ou tel territoire et enfin le rapport
appelle à transformer les modes de
management pour effectivement s'adapter
à la distance merci beaucoup merci
quentin pour ses explications c'est ces
détails
c'est qu'ils gagnent sur l'idée d'être
activité ça chauffe ça vraiment
intéressant là la concurrence entre pays
on peut même dire concurrence entre
régions parfois la vue et on pointe
alors à quelques sur quelques cas
aujourd'hui oui effectivement on
pourrait avoir des entreprises qui
s'expatrient complètement et font du
télétravail depuis l'étranger ça c'est
un risque on pourrait également avoir
effectivement cette concurrence entre
des territoires au sein de notre pays
parce que la vue y compris dans les
premiers à qualifier d exode urbain
poste qu'ovide tout le monde ne s'exerce
pas partout et on conserve quand même
l'armature de la ville moyenne à
proximité souvent d'une gare de tgv donc
ce n'est pas non plus l'alpha et l'oméga
pour tous les territoires ruraux et est
ce que nous proposons et ans à être
attentifs à cela pour éviter la
compétitivité la concurrence entre les
territoires je crois qu'au contraire
tout le monde doit pouvoir bénéficier de
ces nouvelles installations est ce que
constater moi je le constate dans mon
département de la loire mais tout je me
constatons au collègue également qui
était co rapporteurs sénateur du cantal
c'est ce besoin quand même qu'ils
s'expriment des fameux détient lieu des
espaces de coworking chacun appelle à
comme le jeu voilà en la matière qui
peuvent aussi permettre justement ce que
j'évoquais tout à l'heure d'éviter le
travail à la maison ou l isolement
ravaille tout seul et finalement de
garder un temps où je sors de chez moi
je vais travailler j'ai un lieu de
travail et j'ai un lieu de vie mon lieu
de vie reste mon lieu de ma famille nous
lieu personnel moulu avec mes amis
s'apprêtent à verser le mélange des deux
est pas si simple psychologiquement
surtout quand quand on est dans un lieu
de vie qui est pas forcément très très
grand en superficie devrait rester sur
cette notion d'attractivité laurence
breton aucune y est ce qu'il ya des
secteurs
à côté ou sous cette concurrence
finalement lié au télétravail elle est
déjà à l'oeuvre oui dans le monde de
lahti depuis un moment déjà c'est un
monde sous tension et tu voi haïti c'est
quoi toutes les nouvelles et sa mère vit
tous eu toutes les 16 d'ozil voilà ce
qui travaillent saisi société de
services informatiques les serristes
dans le marketing digital dans le
numérique en fait tous les métiers où on
est déjà une tension forte et donc
effectivement c'est au plus offrant ce
qu'on n'offre pas en rémunération
l'offre en compensation mais parfois ce
sont des métiers qui sont des métiers
solitaire pour certains donc ce qui
n'est pas représentatif mais c'est vrai
que nous on prête attention au niveau
d'un barrage parce que nous on a fait
des propositions
j'ai pas si vous souvenez mais en 2007 à
l'époque en fait on remboursait pas 50%
des forfaits d'abonnement des transports
c'est à dire que pour la personne pour
qu'elle ait 50 % il fallait que son
conjoint et ses enfants ne puissent pas
déménager et sinon on ne prenait pas en
charge ce qu'on se rend compte
aujourd'hui avec de télétravail dans les
accords autres c'est qu'effectivement
chacun peut habiter où il veut la seule
chose c'est qu'ils gardent les salaires
de la région parisienne et qui demandent
le remboursement de 50% des frais
transport voilà la seule chose c'est que
nous c'est pas des modèles je dire alors
en dehors de ça après il ya la fatigue
ce que ca banon la réunion 9h30 c'est
pas possible on qui il faut quand même
est effectivement se projeter donc déjà
on demande à ce que l'on puisse revenir
dessus puisque le choix de chacun où il
habite en tout cas dans le périmètre
france est ce qu on est souvent dans nos
accords chacun peut choisir mais ce
n'est pas l'entreprise d'assumer
financièrement les frais sont changement
d'organisation ça c'est le premier point
le deuxième point ce qu'on demande c'est
que le code du travail évolue
aujourd'hui en tant qu'employeur on est
responsable dans nos cours on vérifie
tout soit aux normes etc demain on fait
déjà dans beaucoup d'accords signés des
décharges en disant je m'engage sur
l'honneur je suis conforme au niveau
électrique au niveau assurantielle au
niveau de l'environnement de travail
mais ça ne vaut rien juridiquement
parlant je veux dire voilà et donc aux
demandes effectivement changé ah oui
qu'est-ce qui se passe ces prêts en
compte nous on a eu une descente
d'escalier entre le bureau et la cuisine
est en fait un excellent travail c'est
un accident du travail et après on aura
aussi en nous disant psychologiquement
vous m'avez laissé à la maison il y
avait ma famille j'avais beaucoup de
tension enfin si vous voulez c'est le
début en tout cas le code du travail tel
qu'il est construit n'est pas protecteur
pour le nouveau monde donc il faut qu'il
est venu mais c'est intéressant parce
que corriger il ya aussi
les salariés qui travaillent pour des
entreprises par multinationales ou des
grandes entreprises anglo-saxonnes qui
ont été placés en télétravail et qui
pour certains ou certaines sont
entraidés travaille depuis deux ans ils
sont pratiquement pas revenu au bureau
ou alors ils sont à peine revenu qu'ils
étaient repartis où là c'est quoi le
réflexe est plutôt l'entreprise qui a
peur d'être mise en cause par son
salarié s'il attrape locaux vides au
bureau et qui se prémunit d'une
éventuelle procédure c'est comment vous
expliquer cette différence de
d'appréciation du télétravail entre des
grandes entreprises de droit anglo saxon
et où des entreprises françaises
non répondent sur cette question
pourrait même très précise
mais c'est vrai que oui on observe des
comportements extrêmement différentes
selon les entreprises mais ça veut dire
qu'il va y avoir ça existe déjà mais des
inégalités entre salariés français en
fonction d'eux des groupes pour lesquels
ou des entreprises pour lesquelles ils
travaillent ils seront pas soumis aux
mêmes télétravail ou est ce que je veux
dire oui enfin des inégalités dans la
société française on a déjà énormément
donc voilà donc effectivement on sait on
sait bien effectivement la possibilité
de télétravailler ou pas mais comme vous
disiez il ya aussi du télétravail contre
un bon c'est pas on se sait pas si c'est
un plus ou pas c'est vraiment du cas par
cas
mon des choses a
constaté ça dépend de son activité sa
déjà dépens de soi ça dépend si on est
une femme aussi mon homme et comme des
os et des inégalités très fort si on en
parle parlons-en effectivement ça se
pose pas de la même façon pour une femme
de travailler au domicile à 1 donc il ya
effectivement un risque plus de
surcharge aussi parce que quand je suis
que le travail domestique le travail
professionnel etc voilà donc on sait que
effectivement il ya souvent aussi un nom
on se met aussi soit même plus de
pression il ya parfois des supérieurs
qui ont des injonctions des
prescriptions beaucoup plus forte et
donc il ya des situations de surcharge
importante donc voilà effectivement il
ya des pratiques très différentes
mathieu je pense qu'on peut faire le
parallèle avec le temps partiel vous
êtes en temps partiel choisi temps
partiel subi ça n'a absolument rien à
voir et se dire je prends le mercredi
après midi pour m'occuper de mes enfants
ou être une caissière sur un superbe
dans un supermarché qui attend sur le
parking pendant trois heures de
reprendre sa caisse et qui repose deux
heures et qui les attend trois heures
parce qu'elle entend par sienne c'est
pas du tout la même histoire et si on ne
réglemente pas si on ne peut repenser
pas ce n'est pas juste une affaire de
réglementation si on ne change pas de
culture de sur notre rapport au travail
on aura les mêmes dérives autre que la
même dichotomie dans le salariat que sur
le temps partiel j'aimerais qu'on parle
maintenant de la grande émission alors
c'était le titre
de nos confrères le magazine le point il
ya quelques il ya quelques jours il ya
quelques semaines on va voir la une du
point je pense qu'on l'a qu'on l'a
retrouvé voilà une de poing le spectre
de la grande des missions sa part
d'abord d'un phénomène américain on a
entendu dans le le sujet ça me déchire
tout à l'heure 38 millions de démission
sur l'année 2000 21 4 millions et demi
sur le seul mois de novembre 2000 21
c'est le ministère américain du travail
qui donne ces chiffres est ce que le
rendre autant que ni la france est
confrontée alors une vaguelette on va
dire de démission ou même pas
je dirais même page et je dirais qu'on a
un mode qui est très différent que la
grande émission une personne qui demande
une rupture conventionnelle si vous
voulez pour moi ça s'appelle pas une
grande émission ça s'appelle comment je
veux profiter pendant un temps de pôle
emploi d'accord donc ça c'est un petit
peu le problème oui mais c'est quand
même le même signe d'un éloignement du
travail ou discuter de ce qui était son
mode de travail on peut quand même
l'analyser comme ça je pense que nous
compenser une beaucoup de personnes sont
perdus c'est à dire qu'elles sont mal
vécu cette période qu vide on n'a pas
tous on en parlait tout à l'heure on vit
pas tous dans le même environnement
et c'est vrai que ceux qui avaient une
famille pas trop un espace assez grands
ont vécu cette période de façon beaucoup
plus positive que des personnes
effectivement qu'il était isolé après on
a eu le cas aussi des métiers durs en
parle effectivement de la restauration
et d'autres métiers où les personnes à
se sont rendu compte il y avait une
autre vie c'est à dire la vie de famille
et c'est donc ça bouscule et leur valeur
moi le problème que j'ai c'est pas quand
la personne est un expert en haïti s'ils
démissionnent demain et change la vie
après demain c'est bon ce qui m'inquiète
beaucoup c'est les personnes qui sont
dans des métiers pour lesquels si elle
s'arrête de travailler demain et bien
entraînements je sais pas si elles
pourront recommencer à trouver un emploi
voyez et donc il faut qu'on prête
attention c'est pour ça qu'on refuse
beaucoup de ruptures conventionnelles
les uns et les autres sauces il ya m
évidemment des projets parce qu'en plus
c'est ni à nous en tant qu'entreprise ni
finalement à l'ensemble des personnes de
soutenir des noms projets qui sont
plutôt un malaise une envie de
changer est ce que ces demandes de
ruptures conventionnelles sont en
augmentation oui oui ça c'est la vie
parce que le système et alléger
moi si vous voulez certains ont
peut-être trop travailler mais d'autres
ont passé travaillé et donc quand on
travaille moi on à moi cette appétence
cette valeur du travail et nous on l'a
on l'a vu en moi je suis contre le foot
travail contre le travail à 100% l'autre
qu'elle travaille à 100% assez horrible
on à moi j'ai vu des cas où le lien se
distend avec une entreprise qui au bout
d'un moment vous n'avez pas envie de
revenir travailler vous dit à quoi çà et
là en fait ce qu'on a remarqué dans
cette crise c'est cette individualité
qui est sorti moi je alors lis moi je
travaille bien mais mais c'est faux
parce que quand vous parliez la
productivité moi je suis pas d'accord la
productivité en télétravail elle
augmente et après diminue parce que de
nos contacts sociaux dont on parlait en
fait on a ce qu'on appelle la
sérendipité on se parle est une chose
que vous dit
quoi là tout à fait et quand vous êtes
seul en fait au départ c'est vrai vous
avez une productivité parce que vous
êtes en fait sur des bases que vous
connaissez et après ça diminue parce que
d'isolement n'est pas bon et puis nous
on a aussi remarqué beaucoup d'addiction
niveau de la ndr h on a beaucoup
travaillé la diction c'est pas que
l'alcool c'est les médicaments c'est
l'hyper connexion et caetera et tous
ceux qui avaient des troubles de santé
mentale avant de partir et bien la
situation s'est dégradée donc en fait il
faut c'est ce que j'aime bien quand vous
dites le télétravail en fait c'est pas
la panacée ça doit être utilisé avec
méthode et ça convient pas tout le monde
oui mais au delà du télétravail là on
est vraiment sur 1
l'éloignement du travail ou même de la
valeur travail dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure tu sais pas comment vous
l'analysez aurélie jeantet mais ce
mouvement aux états unis évidemment on
n'a pas du tout le même système social
etc mais si vous nous dites les demandes
de deux ruptures conventionnelles sont
en augmentation s'est passé pas neutre
quoi il ya il ya il ya une peut-être
chez certains une volonté de s'éloigner
de ce qu'ils faisaient l'essentiel de 2
enfin le de leur temps le travail
l'entreprise oui mais là je pense que
peut penser au livre degrés vers les
voltiges les boules shit jabs à dire
effectivement enfin je versais ses
essais en actes en fait une critique du
monde du travail tel qu'il est organisé
aujourd'hui mais beaucoup de personnes
par exemple télétravail et cylia
protecteur parce que le travail
aujourd'hui pathogènes la façon dont il
est organisé dans beaucoup d'entreprises
ça fait souffrir voilà donc après c'est
évident c'est pas une réponse de
télétravailler ou d'être mais c'est vous
devez démissionner conjoncture
indépendant c'est un peu la même journée
on fait de la danse et une dans une
protection dans un dans sa retraite ans
un éloignement et effectivement ce qui
se passe aux etats unis ce qui se passe
un petit peu en france aussi
effectivement les serveurs qui veulent
plus retourner bosser ce mais à quoi bon
en fait je perds ma vie à la gagner à
toutes ces slogans et qui était déjà une
critique du travail élaborée dans les
années 70 mais revient et effectivement
il faut il faut repenser un petit peu
notre travail est ce que ça a du sens
est-ce que c'est dans des conditions qui
nous permette effectivement d'être en
lien cette dimension de socialisation
par exemple désolé mais aujourd'hui on
est dans des rapports très
individualiste de mise en concurrence
des personnes entre elles et c'est donc
ça n'a pas forcément cette fonction donc
voilà notre faut s'interroger et
peut-être effectivement en profiter pour
réformer restructurer repenser les
organisations il travaille je vous donne
la parole à un autre chiffre pour
alimenter le débat sur ce baromètre de
la formation et de l'emploi de 21 49 %
des travailleurs qui on parle des
français qui envisagent de changer
d'emploi à court ou moyen terme un
travailleur sur sur deux je pose un peu
la même question sur l'éloignement de
l'emploi ou et vous pourrez répondre
après le finalement le la pierre dans le
jardin des entreprises sur ce qui était
l'organisation du travail et ce qu'elles
peuvent améliorer à 7 pour certaines on
va pas être dans l'amalgamé pour
certains secteurs ou pour certaines
entreprises moi je pense et je vais le
dire très tranquillement comparaison
n'est pas toujours raison le système
américain n'est pas le nôtre et même si
nous sommes en français que je retiens
c'est que ce qui se passe aux etats unis
les conditions de travail aux etats-unis
ne sont pas elle mais l'enchaînement
france est sûre je travaille sur 21 des
émissions jagellon actuellement de gens
qui ont du sens ensuite je pense que
nous avons vécu une crise sanitaire dont
par le clown la question sanitaire mais
cette crise elle nous a profondément
marqué dans nos façons de vivre et
d'être faut quand même s'imaginer que
pendant deux mois la plupart des
français se sont retrouvés chez eux à
s'interroger sur ce qu'ils étaient sur
ce qu'ils faisaient et sur ce qu'ils
allaient faire don je refuserais
question est-ce que ça doit pousser les
entreprises peuvent faire des randonnées
attendre laurence breton cugn après aaa
ses langes et de blues wesh
d'organisation la seule un des grands
métiers aujourd'hui c'est l'hôtellerie
restauration voilà eux ça n'a pas été de
moi ça a duré parce qu'on a eu les
couvre-feux ensuite quoi souffre moins
des deux années et oui on a des gens
alors ils ne répondent pas à leurs
questions de demande ce qu'ils vont
faire parce que tout le monde ne sera
pas auto entrepreneurs tout le monde ne
sera pas indépendant tout le monde ne
sera pas
aromathérapeute où on plein d'autres
professions certainement nous avons
besoin et on ne fera pas ça demain mais
pour autant nous avons effectivement de
plus en plus de français qui se sont ré
interroger sur ce qu'il faisait et qu'il
ne voulait plus faire et sur ce qu'ils
imaginaient parce que c'est j'en reviens
à ce que j'ai initialement sur ce qu'ils
imaginent de ce que pourrait être un
autre métier que lawler par rapport à
l'image qu'ils en ont quelques bons dans
d'autres métiers ce serait bien parce
que je ne pourrais je pourrais
effectivement d'où la question quand je
cherche un un job aujourd'hui je
pourrais faire un ou deux jours de
télétravail sans m'interroger sur nère
les conséquences que cela peut avoir sur
mon travail donc oui on a effectivement
comme dans toute période de tension et
la crise sanitaire est sympa de très
long terme de tension forcément des gens
qui se ré interroge eux mêmes sur à quoi
bon à quoi sert ce que je fais moi j'ai
discuté concret avec des cadres la
période du télétravail par exemple moi
j'ai l'exemple d'une entreprise dans mon
département ou basse et les cadres qu'on
est en difficulté parce que dans une
entreprise industrielle les ouvriers eux
ont continué de venir les cadres qui
étaient si l'emportant avant eux étaient
restés chez eux continuer de travailler
jo je vois aux toilettes rails mais
méfions je suis premier qui arrive le
dernier qui parle là de chez moi
illégale ils ont continué de quoi jouer
comme ça saisir excusez-moi illégale ils
ont continué de faire tourner la boîte
bon mais j'ai l'impression qu'il n'avait
plus le temps des cadeaux tout ça je
vais bien dit la presse mais
l'impression bien évidemment mais tout
ça bouleverse je crois chacun dans son
rapport au trail sa place dans
l'entreprise et donc cette envie
soudaine de partir pour faire autre
chose mais fiction à vous et je vous
rejoins
attention parce que entre l' envie de
faire autre chose et la capacité de
faire autre chose sur le long terme il
peut être parfois quelques voitures non
vie des salariés pardon mais aussi la
responsabilité des entreprises est cette
grande émission elle est quand même
porté par deux phénomènes le premier
c'est la quête de sens que vous décrivez
l'adhésion à un projet collectif et là
de la part des entreprises ils vont
devoir repenser ce qu'il propose comme
projet comme des cinq hommes grand
dessein comme intégration dans ce modèle
là il faut faire rêver un peu arrivent à
l'âge d'un an un chiffre qui
qui va dans votre sens 78 % des 18-24
ans qui veulent un emploi qui a un sens
pour eux donc ça énorme boulot pour les
entreprises l'autre énorme révolution
copernicienne pour l'entreprise c'est
que la grande émission elle s'explique
aussi quand on est dans des zones en
tension pénurie de main d'oeuvre et que
ça fait des années on n'a pas à
articuler la répartition de la valeur
ajoutée enfin qu'elle a toujours
bénéficié au capital est beaucoup
beaucoup plus rarement au travail ça
fait des années qu'on dit aux salariés
quand ça ne va pas on ne peut pas vous
augmentez quand ça va mieux il faut
qu'on reconstitue les marges tu vas
falloir attendre et là on arrive à un
moment économique ou quand on atteint un
taux de chômage je m'appelle structurel
c'est à dire on arrivera à une zone de
friction qui fait que les demandes ne
peuvent enfin les offres peuvent
dépasser les demandes eh ben il ya des
zones de tension est donc c'est la
politique salariale la politique de
rémunération au delà du salaire de ce
que je propose aux salariés et les
entreprises vont devoir reporter
activement ses seins c'est intéressant
dans ce vote ont cueilli on l'a vu avec
le secteur chr café hôtellerie
restauration et finalement eu 16 %
d'augmentation de salaire proposé donc
les marges a exalté la taille est un peu
c'est un peu sous la pression de la
crise est due et de la capacité de la
grande difficulté à recruter que
finalement certains patrons ont lâché
vous voyez ce que je veux dire oui enfin
c'est une situation particulière parce
que on va dire qu'il partait de bas
quand même par rapport à d'autres oui
mais il croit pas plus tôt alors je suis
pas dans je suis pas dans le domaine
après de la problématique j'entends
c'est toujours cette généralité dénoncer
toutes les entreprises gagnent de
l'argent quand on fait des études vous
avez mal emplois en france et pas les
entreprises du cac 40 ou d'usb s'en va
donc qui est l'un des moyens vous avez
beaucoup de petites entreprises ou
patrons se payant dernier oui prête
attention aussi donc on a des
différences selon l'entreprise dans
laquelle on est après on travaille quand
même beaucoup sur le sens il ya eu la
loi pas la raison d'être on essaye de
tout mettre en oeuvre en tout cas nous l
andrh on est drh donc ça fait aussi
partie de notre adn parce que c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué d'attirer des
talents que de garder ses talents donc
on a tout ce travail à faire ce qu'on
appelle la marque employeur oui mais
encore faut-il avoir les moyens je veux
dire toutes les entreprises n'ont pas
tiré leur épingle du jeu c'est le cas ce
que le dire pendant ces deux dernières
années en revanche ce qu'il faut
toujours pour moi savoir beaucoup de
transparence et parler d'adulte à adulte
on a de la chance que même en france
d'avoir un dialogue social de qualité en
tout cas c'est le cas chez moi avec mes
délégués syndicaux quel que soit en fait
leur obédience et c'est vrai il faut
être transparent pour dire quand ça va
quand ça va pas et quand ça va pouvoir
faire de partage de la valeur ça on
trouve ça en tout cas nous un vrai sujet
il faut savoir quand même qu'au niveau
des drh en fin 2021 on avait bien sûr la
santé qualité de vie au travail qui
arrivait en premier mais c'était
directement suivie par la responsabilité
sociale de l'entreprise parce que c'est
vraiment une chose qui attire beaucoup à
la fois y as il ya cette caisse de sens
mais il ya les valeurs on doit partager
des valeurs de l'entreprise dans
laquelle on est alors puis quand
puisqu'on se projette dans le futur de
de nos organisations du travail serait
qu'on parle de la semaine de quatre
jours mais maintenant c'est le futur et
c'est tout à fait actuel un premier
exemple d'entreprise une société de
vente de matériel informatique
dans laquelle flora sauvage s'était
enduit il ya quelques semaines pour pour
public sénat on regarde un extrait le
patron explique pourquoi il est passé
aux 32 heures regardez les gens font en
quatre jours et en 32 heures le travail
qu'ils faisaient avant 35 ans voire je
pense même qu en réalité sont encore
plus efficace que ça on a gagné en
efficacité
et donc je leur ai demandé mais comment
vous sentez est ce que vous êtes stressé
est ce que l on fait ça les faisait
sourire quand je parlais tout ça parce
que que valence et non on se sent bien
on est heureux et effectivement on fait
le même travail qu'avant mais on est
reposée c'est plus la même semaine
pourtant au départ certains salariés
sont dubitatifs à l'instar de jean
claude qui a choisi le vendredi comme
jours off j'étais un petit peu sceptique
je ne savais pas comment j'allais
rentrer l'intégralité de mes tâches
d'enfin dans quatre jours a fait déjà du
mal sur 5 il a fait contre d'heerenveen
de nouvelles ressources finalement nous
optimiser le temps de travail les
salariés sont unanimes au siège comme
dans les boutiques de l'entreprise a
donc les pièces sont garantis 2 ans en
boutique c'est un souci au passé
directement vers mes collègues à
l'atelier à la semaine aussi parce
beaucoup plus vite
psychologiquement c'est ça rien à voir
et même un petit regain de julian
motivation parce que du coup on envie de
s'investir un petit peu plus dans la
dans la boutique dans la société un
autre exemple celui
de l'entreprise le buzz fillon pme de
plomberie chauffage on est avec son
dirigeant luc barillon bonsoir merci
d'avoir accepté notre invitation et
bousculer un peu votre emploi du temps
pour être présents dans dans l'émission
vous avez repris cette entreprise en
2019 et vous êtes passé à la semaine de
quatre jours expliquez-nous pourquoi
alors bonsoir mesdames messieurs alors
oui je suis passé à 4 jours alors la
janais histoire en fait j'ai repris
cette entreprise en octobre 2019 c'est
une entreprise avec treize salariés
d'entreprises que je connaissais bien
puisque l'ancien gérant était à mes
anciens collaborateurs
puisque j'ai eu à passer dans un groupe
pendant 23 ans
donc voila moi je suis venu avec mes
convictions de peut-être un peu nos
routes mais surtout de développer cette
entreprise avec des idées fortes sur
sûre pour m'aider à développer sur
notamment le des process d'achat des
process marketing de communication voilà
et pour se faire rapidement jeu j'avais
déjà songé à se retrouver avec des
problèmes de
paiement donc pour se faire
jour dans le dur pourquoi la semaine de
quelques jours expliquez moi
parce qu'en fait c'est toujours ses
poupées noires madame moi je suis dans
un métier sous tension
difficile
avec notamment d'amazon de change is le
sud touraine une pénurie de demain de la
tendance est à cette activité donc
rapidement il fallait choix inventif
temps sur le côté social sociétal
économique
pour développer l'entreprise voilà donc
ça vous a permis de garder vos salariés
et même d'embaucher d'autres d'une
certaine façon alors moi j'ai une
entreprise en demi en octobre 2009
c'était 13 salariés aujourd'hui les 48
avec quatre points de vente
ce qui aujourd'hui déjà nous permet
d'avoir des perspectives de promotion
interne tout ça ça fait ricochet en fait
donc aujourd'hui
bah effectivement sur l'aspect social
bien évidemment comme les précédents
interlocuteur recherche aujourd'hui des
clips privée vie professionnelle
intacte alors il est sage aimait notre
jeu mis en place d'autres éléments et
pour moitié des recrutements
pour une grande entreprise d
intéressement semestrielle des mutuelles
d'entreprise prise en charge bref et
puis sur l'aspect économique on va dire
il a fallu travailler la productivité
donc des livraisons directes chez les
clients pour les charges lourdes adapter
les outils tels que la téléphonie pour
les renvois d'appels les ventilations de
ligne à par métier tapez 1 tapez 2 enfin
bref les outils informatiques
quinze jours s'est aussi adapté s'est
aussi adapté les process dans
l'entreprise je voudrais savoir comment
est ce que vous embauchez encore et
comment vous faites est ce qu'on peut
sais pas je ne sais pas pour l'emploi ou
des ou des agences agences d'intérim ou
autre ouais alors non aujourd'hui le le
recrutement en fait il se fait il se
fait par mes équipes même en fait un bon
pour l'emploi j'ai abandonné le sujet
non non le le le vrai propulseur du
recrutement c'est l'ac milan quatre
jours ça c'est évident voilà merci
beaucoup merci de ce témoignage merci
encore une fois d'avoir adapté votre
emploi du temps pour être présents dans
dans l'émission et la semaine de quatre
jours alors là on a eu deux exemples de
pme mais alors il ya aussi le patron de
total énergie patrick pouyanné qui en
parlait dans les échos il ya quelques
jours je le cite je me demande s'il ne
faudrait pas libérer une demi journée
voire une journée entière pour permettre
aux salariés de s'occuper de leurs
tâches personnelles pour que le reste de
la semaine soit dédié à leur mission
professionnelle orientée à 6,6 total
passe à la semaine de quatre jours là on
est dans un total énergie on est dans un
symbole qui est quand même qui est quand
même très fort c'est l'une des
entreprises franc on se revoyait ce que
je veux dire c'est quelque chose dont on
parle depuis longtemps la semaine de la
réduction des temps de travail à 32
heures ce qui est autre chose que ce qui
a été appliqué là mais bien sûr enfin
c'est un projet de société en fait un
effectivement de retrouver du temps pour
soi tu retrouves est du temps pour ses
voisins pour cesser ses parents de ces
enfants etc voilà je pense qu'il ya
vraiment une rj ans de repenser quand
même la place du travail la fonction
ultra mais si sa place aussi parmi les
autres sphères d'investissement qui sont
aussi extrêmement important et qui sont
producteurs de valeur c'est à dire que
travailler que quatre jours ce pas
forcément dire qu'on ne produit rien les
autres choix donc je pense
qu'effectivement c'est extrêmement
important eq c'est aussi une question
aussi de santé de prévention de
d'attention de care de soins à soi aux
autres et que je pense qu'il ya vraiment
une chance aussi on peut rajouter sur le
plan écologique
parce que je pense qu'effectivement
prendre soin aussi de sa maison de voilà
de cuisine et un petit peu pas jeter que
du tout fait emballer et ses dires c'est
aussi toutes tes habitudes de
consommation déco d'habitude voilà un
rapport aussi à son environnement donc
voilà donc oui bien sûr fait intéressant
la semaine de quatre jours cécile kerman
il faut laisser les entreprises la
mettre en place quand elles sont prêtes
ou alors faire refaire le coup des 35
heures non moi vous savez je pense
d'abord que nous avons une société qui
est en profonde mutation il la sen du
tout plagie jérôme fourquet ou d'autres
qui me dirait bien mieux et nous l'avons
dit sonné en cas de la délégation c'est
à la prospective au lac et qui est
présidée par mon collègue mathieu
darnaud mais je crois que la délégation
à la prospective justement son rôle ici
au sénat c'est de nous sortir la
question et je vais y répondre c'est
mieux vous sortir de jeu fait la loi
tout de suite maintenant et se projeter
parce que en fait la question elle n'est
pas la semaine de quatre de quatre jours
où la semaine de cinq jours un droit
qu'est ce qu'il faut une loi nationale
qu'elle impose pas remis mais pour
l'instant c'est comment est-ce que l'on
re définit le sens du travail et moi je
vois là je pense qu'il faut réduire le
temps de travail parce que nous en avons
la capacité et les moyens et richesse
dans notre pays mais pour une semaine de
quatre jours on peut faire 32 heures par
exemple en travaillant moins tard le
soir donc la question c'est non et ce
book oui c'est pas simplement imposé oui
c'est une souplesse c'est une souplesse
et moi je suis plus pour qu'on la baisse
le nombre d'heures du temps de travail
en road et on redistribue être contré un
certain nombre de richesses etc stable
on n'aurait pas le temps de le
développer ici enfin plutôt que d'être
sur 4 jours ou cinq jours quoi je pense
que la loi elle doit être celle ci est
l'application doit être envoyé
injustement à en redonnant du sens au
travail et aux projets dans l'entreprise
la place des salariés et des différents
acteurs de l'entreprise parce que je
crois que c'est aussi comme ça qu'on
sortira de la situation à laquelle nous
sommes ou quand même on a je le redis
une vraie difficulté sur pourquoi est ce
que nous travaillons merci beaucoup on
termine là dessus merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce débat ici et ans et en
visioconférence aurélie jantes et je
rappelle le titre de votre livre les
émotions au travail publié aux éditions
du cnrs je vous donne rendez vous
évidemment demain pour un nouveau numéro
de sens public et puis ne ratez pas sur
public sénat dans la matinale invités
politiques demain ce sera hervé morin le
président centriste de la région
normande il soutient valérie pécresse
belle soirée à toutes et à tous
[Musique]